- A certified avalanche dog like Tali
can do the work of about 30 rescuers
in the same amount of time.
Their sense of smell is
10 times greater than ours
and if someone's buried in the snow,
or not even buried but
just lost in the woods,
the dog can smell their scent coming up
through the snow pack and
tell me where to start
digging to find that person.
We are the first responders
and a lot of times
if things go well into our training,
we can facilitate that
rescue without putting
anybody else in harm's
way, and be done quickly
and efficiently and all go home safely.
(barks)
We gotta find somebody, I know.
You want to find somebody?
Okay Tali, let's go, search.
My name's Hunter Mortenson.
I'm an Avalanche Technician here
at Breckenridge Ski
Resort with my ski patrol
partner Tali, and we've been working here
for eight years together.
We're really fortunate
here at Breckenridge.
We have six avalanche
rescue dogs on staff.
Today Tali's here with her coworkers
and friends is Boudreaux,
the Golden Retriever,
and Ayup, another mountain purebred mutt.
The years of the big Saint Bernard
and Swiss mountain dog with the barrel
under their neck, those dogs are built
for the mountains, they're
sturdy, they're hardy,
they can do it but what we're finding is
they don't travel well in the snow
and they're not as fast
moving across the snow.
And avalanche rescue is all a matter of time
and so we're looking these days for dogs
that are a little bit on the smaller side,
a little more nimble
and a little more quick.
So the training, we start
them six to nine months old,
and a lot of it is just basic obedience
and then we start building
from the obedience
into actual hide-and-go-seek type games.
And then we build up from there
into big snow caves where we'll bury
a person almost six feet
deep if we have enough snow,
and then the dog will start searching,
having to find where
that scent's coming up
to play the game.
And all they're really
looking for is that person
who they think has their toy.
Ah, that's a good girl.
It's about two full years of training
to take your last certification test
for an avalanche rescue dog and handler.
So I'm certified to work with Tali.
(barks)
My whole last eight years of my career
have been spent with
her every day all day.
When we have to do our thing,
we're really dependent on each other
and I couldn't do what I do without her.
And so it's an amazing partnership
and I'm really honored and proud
to be a part of this program
and work with a dog like her.